[Musique]
bienvenue dans cette émission spéciale
puisqu'elle sera consacrée au procès de
Landru et à une pièce qui s'appelle je
n'ai rien à vous dire qui sera joué les
26 27 et 28 mai prochain où ça à Gambais
Gambais la ville de Londres et pour en
parler Raphaël niveau à bonjour bonjour
à tous alors vous êtes le maire de de
Gambais donc je suppose que à chaque
fois que quelqu'un vous rencontre il
doit vous parler de notre rue c'est ça
ça me fait bizarre à chaque fois que
quand on m'accueille on me dit bonjour
Monsieur le Maire ah bonjour monsieur
Landru comment ça va
quand vous faites la présentation de
l'émission ça me fait toujours quelque
chose de me dire voilà le maire de
Gambais et Landru associé toujours à
Landru mais cela dit votre prédécesseur
pas le prédécesseur direct celui qui
était maire au moment de l'affaire
aujourd'hui a joué un rôle dans son
arrestation
on aura l'occasion d'en parler
Louis bonjour bonjour alors vous êtes le
coteur de cette pièce je n'ai rien à
vous dire et le metteur en scène et puis
vous aussi de oui même un petit rôle le
commissaire qui a arrêté Landru
absolument
bonjour Patrice alors vous avez là-bas
vous avez encore des cheveux vous allez
les perdre 50 % de du visage et c'est
vous qui êtes qui qui serait Landru dans
cette pièce donc le 27 mai c'est le
samedi à 19h30 et le 28 mai à 16h c'est
ça parfaitement alors on va parler quand
même de cette affaire qui est qui est on
a appelé ça de l'affaire du siècle et
c'est vrai quoi tu sais l'affaire du
siècle d'abord d'abord il faut il faut
dire pour les gens qui ne connaîtraient
pas on est on est dans la guerre de 14
les hommes sont beaucoup d'hommes sont
au front beaucoup d'hommes ont été tués
ou blessés il y a beaucoup de femmes
seules ça explique un peu la faire
l'andria exactement
les hommes sont tous au front les femmes
sont seules et en fait l'andru très vite
a compris qu'il y avait quelque chose à
faire parce que le Landru a toujours été
un peu dans l'escroquerie voilà
exactement et en fait il a commencé les
escroquerie au mariage et il publiait
des annonces dans les journaux
dans lesquelles il disait qu'ils
recherchent une femme avec un minimum de
d'argent ou de bien qui séduisait à qui
faisait des promesses de mariage pour
obtenir des procurations et ensuite
vider les comptes et disparaître voilà
et donc voilà il fait des petits
escroqueries et puis et puis il y avait
des femmes qui disparaissent il faut
rappeler que ça se passe à Paris tout ça
se passe à Paris
dans quelques instants oui ça se passe à
Paris et alors dans les dans le procès
alors puisqu'il va y avoir un certain
nombre de femmes qui dispensent combien
de combien de cas sont il était en
relation avec 283 femmes sur une période
de 4 ans donc c'est déjà énorme et sur
les 283 il a été jugé pour le meurtre de
diffams et d'un enfant de 17 ans je
crois en plus un adolescent du coup
parce qu'il voilà les autres il y a eu
je crois d'autres disparus qu'on n'a
jamais réellement retrouvé mais qu'on
n'a jamais pu rapprocher à la rue et
après il y a des femmes ou juste Landru
comme elle n'avait pas de bien se
contenter de les séduire et
disparaissait
il arrive juste enfin pendant cette
première guerre mondiale de toute façon
en pleine période de cette de cette
première guerre et il prenait justement
le fameux train voilà le fameux train
pour aller à Gambais le fameux drain
Paris Houdeng oui il y a pas de train
il y a pas de guerre à Gobet même si
aujourd'hui le maire de Gambais aimerait
bien avoir une gare hein parce que
aujourd'hui on parle beaucoup de
mobilité voilà mais non il y a jamais eu
de gare à Gambais donc René il prenait
donc Paris ou dans ce fameux deux allées
un retour alors là il faut expliquer ça
oui voilà bah oui parce que en fin de
compte il savait très bien qu'il y avait
très bien voilà qui repartirait seul
après à Paris tout à fait c'est souvent
j'ai remarqué ça avec criminalistes font
parfois piqué parce qu'ils sont radins
et là c'était un peu de buralisme il
faut parce qu'il aurait pu payer deux
allers-retours non je pense que c'était
prémédité voilà c'était prémédité tout à
fait
j'imagine qu'on va parler mais ce fameux
carnet noir dans lequel c'était un livre
de compte en fait et c'était dans le
livre de conte qu'il notait toujours
c'est deux allées un retour et donc
indépendamment du la radinerie c'était
surtout cette espèce de voilà être
cadrée tout noté tout consigner et c'est
ça
mais jusqu'au point où
l'habitation quand il venait à Gambais
de Paris à Gambais il ne venait pas dans
n'importe quelle maison il avait choisi
une ville qui était en location donc on
voyait un locataire voilà il était
locataire il était locataire de cette
villa à Gambais et une belle villa une
belle maison qui existe toujours un très
très aujourd'hui à chaque fois que vous
avez des touristes ou des visiteurs qui
viennent tout le monde veut la voir même
quand je reçois les collègues voilà on
la voit alors on a une petite ça c'était
une petite annonce parce que il y a
quelques années 2019 je crois ouais elle
vient d'être mise en vente en 2000 enfin
elle a été plusieurs fois mise en vente
et récemment elle était mise en vente en
2019 c'est une maison privée ou une
maison privée voilà non il y a pas un
musée
en 19 en 2019 on nous a demandé quand la
dernière vente a eu lieu si la commune
allait pas l'appréhenter pour pour en
faire quelque chose pour en faire soit
un musée soit pourquoi pas un théâtre
pourquoi pas quelque chose pour pour
refaire vivre encore ce moment de
l'histoire de Gambais il faut bien dire
que Gambais aujourd'hui associé à cette
dramatique histoire Sylvia dramatique
histoire
si on va voir parce qu'il est peut-être
des doutes
c'est vrai que il se passe beaucoup de
choses à Corbeil voilà c'est une ville
très
très très vivante mais c'est vrai qu'il
y a ce il y a Landru quoi tout à fait il
y a Landru il y a l'endroit qui colle
comme on dit à la peau des mères qui
succèdent
et la maison alors par curiosité les
vaches et qui a acheté mais ça reste
alors entre nous euh ça reste des
notables toujours qui voilà qui c'est
une belle villa la preuve on l'appelle
la Villa donc c'est une belle maison
avec un très beau terrain qui est en
recul du centre du centre de la ville de
Gambais donc qui est vraiment de belles
constructions donc voilà très très
réputé aussi très prestigieuse parfois
avec les propriétaires est-ce qu'ils
sont oui bien sûr quand on parce que
quand on achète des occasions comme ça
je pense qu'on achète l'histoire aussi
pour pour certains hein ça c'est clair
parce que vous disiez que c'était une
histoire de Gambais mais je rajouterais
je suis tout à fait d'accord avec vous
mais je rajoute aussi que c'est
l'histoire de France dans la mesure
absolument Landru est considéré comme le
le premier tueur en série c'est un
français et c'est pour ça que je pense
qu'il a une
symbolique ou une aura très forte dans
le sens où avant Landru on n'a pas connu
ça en France on dit que c'est le premier
serial killer
le céréales
c'est vrai que c'est vrai qu'on
employait pas le non l'expression de ces
réalités
puisque comme vous le disiez ne
serait-ce qu'au procès et il y en a sans
doute peut-être d'autres d'autres
victimes enfin il y avait au moins 10
victimes quoi au moins ça c'était 11
victimes ce qui est intéressant c'est
qu'on lui on lui a pose le 10 céréales
killer mais il y a dans ces liker enfin
pour moi il y a toujours cette
inconscient de quelque chose de
psychologique on regarde peut-être Bundy
tout ça il y a quelque chose de de
profondément psychologique et là en fait
c'était il tuait plus pour couvrir ses
arrières je pense qu'il y avait pas de
c'est pas voilà c'est par intérêt
exactement c'est pas du tout oui c'est
pas c'est pas comme ça
qui a une offense à réparer enfin je
sais pas une misère quelconque donc là
c'est visiblement enfin d'après ce qu'on
sait c'est pas la pas du gain quoi et
ben en fait il y a même des journalistes
à l'époque ça a jamais été prouvé de
façon concrète mais il y a des gens qui
ont pensé à un moment ils se sont
intéressés sur les 283 femmes il y a pas
eu que 11 escroquerie il y en a eu
beaucoup beaucoup et il y a des
journalistes qui se sont intéressés à
l'époque de demander qu'est-ce qui
s'était passé dans la tête de landrus
qu'il a commencé ses arnaques très tôt
très vite je veux dire dès le début si
c'était pas l'esprit au mariage c'était
les escroquets ou cautionnement et ils
iraient également des séjours en prison
et quand il a commencé à se croquer
toutes ces femmes
elles ne disparaissait pas porter
plainte et lui aller régulièrement en
prison et des journalistes ont émis
l'hypothèse à l'époque
qu'au bout d'un moment à un énième
séjour en prison il s'est dit bon on va
peut-être
ouvrir césarienne et c'est pour ça qu'a
priori il aurait pris après
le parti de les de les faire disparaître
pour ne pas laisser de traces oui parce
que oui il y a des survivants évidemment
bien sûr
elles ont témoigné au procès il y en a
beaucoup alors c'est souvent des des
sœurs des des proches de la famille qui
voilà qui ont dit voilà on l'a reconnu
des concierges immeubles qui disent oui
c'est ce monsieur qu'on a vu nous
rapporter une lettre ou déménager
l'appartement de Madame untel il y a un
témoignage de procès qui est assez je
dirais pas Sélène mais qui est un peu
resté c'est celui de Fernande Segré qui
est la dernière en fait amante de Landru
et les relations qu'ils entretenaient
l'un et l'autre sont un peu
avec Gauthier on a une on a une analyse
à force de lire et de répéter on se dit
mais en fait je pense que Landru a
réellement aimé cette femme mais mais
réellement ce qu'il n'aurait jamais ce
qu'elle n'avait pas de bien
et nous deux on est convaincu que si
nombreux étaient réellement coupable de
tout ça qui l'aurait arrêté en fait par
amour pour faire un Andes et elle en
fait à témoigner au procès donc du coup
en faveur totale de Landru et après à
déménagé je sais plus quel pays
je crois
elle a déménagé elle a déménagé à
l'étranger assez loin en tout cas je
crois elle est restée fille au Père
là-bas pendant 40 ans il est revenu en
France et elle s'est suicidé je crois 60
ans jour pour jour après l'exécution de
l'embryon
sur l'arrestation comment ça se passe
l'arrestation de nombreux
le commissaire justement
l'arrestation de landruz il sait faire
arrêter de façon tout à fait je dirais
stupide dans le sens où il était alors
je n'ai plus le nom de la boutique mais
c'était une boutique d'argenterie et en
fait il allait commander un service en
argent et il a été repéré par la il se
faire connaître par la soeur de sa
première ou deuxième victime qui
immédiatement appelle le commissariat
pour dire j'ai retrouvé monsieur Landru
il est là il est là et en fait les
policiers ont accouru immédiatement
parce qu'elle la suit en fait jusqu'au
jusqu'à l'immeuble où il habitait à
l'époque donc ces rues de Rochechouart
et le soleil est en tombé il n'avait pas
le droit de l'arrêter immédiatement donc
ils ont campé devant l'immeuble toute la
nuit alors après la légende et certains
films vous montrent que Belin
se couche devant la porte de landrume et
non Belin a attendu dans le hall n'a pas
fermé l'oeil de la nuit en fait à 6h du
matin
sont aller à qui est parti enchantement
adieu ma petite table
enfin c'est ce que montre en tout cas
l'un des films
vous dites l'andouille c'est son prénom
il s'appelle Henri désiré l'Android mais
mais il avait beaucoup de monde
d'emprunt
s'est fait arrêter sous le nom de Lucien
Guillet qui était le dernier nom entre
guillemets que les policiers avaient en
leur possession
mais il y en a eu plein il a pris le nom
de Madame Cuchet il faisait appeler
Raymond Diard monsieur Frémiet et c'est
sous cette identité là qui louait la
Villa trique
en plus de noms de famille gambaisiennes
là vous venez d'évoquer la famille Guy
par exemple la famille gay est une
famille
donc vous voyez toute l'ambiguïté
[Musique]
vu que voilà il louait beaucoup c'est
voilà cette cette vie là il a loué donc
en prenant des noms d'emprunt toute
l'ambiguïté après pour les enquêteurs
toute la difficulté après des enquêteurs
donc sur cette cette
histoire et le nom QG et le nom de sa
première victime qui l'a repris après
pour ses escroquerie
ça se passait comment c'est à dire que
on voit bien il amène il amène des
femmes séduisent supposons qui sont
coupables après on parlera du procès
mais il a fallu des femmes chez lui il
les tue il est fait brûler les corps
quand même
on en parlera tout à l'heure la fameuse
cuisinière qui était c'est un petit
modèle donc pour brûler un corps en
entier ça devait être un peu compliqué
tout ça c'est du conditionnel absolument
oui voilà
l'escroquerie en gros comment ça se
passait il prenait des femmes qui
avaient des biens
en fait il pue des petites annonces il
recevaient des réponses exactement il
rencontrait ses femmes et euh voilà si
il sentait qu'il y avait des biens parce
que à l'époque il y avait pas que les
biens pécunis aussi le mobilier qui
était très important qui revendait en
fait et si vous voyez que la femme en
question avait beaucoup de mobilier
assez prestigieux beaucoup de bien en
fait il
l'amadoué en fait ces femmes là en leur
faisant promettre le mariage et il les
mettait dans une situation de deux de
telles confiance que elle finissait
toutes par le signer des procurations
avec lesquelles il avait vidé les
comptes il allait après disparition
vider les les les
appartements aidés par ses enfants
et avant de les meubles et c'est comme
ça qui qui vivaient finalement
et donc les femmes tombaient toutes
généralement
dans lequel il est arrêté là il vivait
avec sa femme avec sa maîtresse Fernande
avec Fernando ah bah il était toujours
marié
avec sa cousine Marie Catherine Rémy
et il a eu trois enfants je crois et il
continuait à payer l'éducation de ses
enfants à faire tourner son ménage il a
jamais arrêté en fait c'est juste qu'il
avait
sa dernière à menthe Fernande et il
vivait avec elle au moment de son
arrestation
dans le procès dit avec tout le scandale
qu'on a fait autour de mon nom on a
appris à ma pauvre femme que je l'avais
trompé
oh sa femme a des doutes très très vite
parce qu'on va parler parce que il y a
aussi du cours de l'ordre
de quel point il avait un
bagoule incroyable c'est aussi
monstrueux qu'il est qu'il est qu'il est
pu être pour ne pas être mais il avait
un une façon une aisance avec les mots
qu'on a essayé de montrer dans la pièce
en tout cas mais quelque chose il était
très très culotté il envoyait des pics
très personnels à certains membres enfin
voilà au président à la en général il y
avait quelque chose où il nous aime
vraiment c'est ce qui va être montré
lors de la pièce justement on va parler
à la fois du procès de la pièce puisque
la pièce c'est le procès de l'autre côté
et je n'ai rien à vous dire là c'est
quoi et ben c'est une phrase que l'andru
a répété en boucle pendant 3 semaines
pendant son procès il n'a pas arrêté à
des questions un peu donc là vous voyez
généralement qui joue la vocale générale
oui tout à fait romain pyrosa
et c'est une phrase en fait à chaque
question je dirais un peu
gênante pour Landru ou un peu
problématique pour Landru c'est une fête
il se réfugier derrière cette phrase je
n'ai rien à vous dire vous voyez qu'on
avocat alors je vous attends un petit
instant on est dedans en ligne avec
Vincent couronne bonjour Vincent
bonjour Patrice bonjour à tous alors
Vincent couronnes et
Dr endroit il enseigne notamment à
Sciences Po Saint-Germain et je lui ai
demandé de
venir de vous parler quelques instants
parce que il y a une dizaine d'années en
2014 je crois
l'université la faculté de droit
2017-2017
n'est pas
[Rires]
l'université de de droit de Versailles
Saint-Quentin le fac de droit pardon a
refait le procès de Landru et vous étiez
l'avocat de l'andru c'est ça
tout à fait j'étais l'avocat de la
défense mais ce que je tiens à dire
c'est que lors de ce de ce procès qu'on
a rejoué dans la salle même où l'on dru
au palais de justice de Versailles à
lui-même était jugé
on n'a pas refait le procès tel qu'il
s'est passé on n'a pas repris à
l'identique c'était vraiment de refaire
le procès c'est-à-dire de le juger à
nouveau
exactement comme si il se déroulait
aujourd'hui avec le droit d'aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs donc condamnait pas on
pouvait pas le condamner à mort
typiquement
mais c'était voilà une expérience quand
même assez assez extraordinaire parce
que tiens à dire que ce procès était
organisé chaque année il y a une
association des étudiants en droit de la
faculté droite de l'Université de
Versailles Saint-Quentin qui organise ça
fait juris tribune
qui organise un procès en reconstitution
voilà voir les images en effet et ce
sont les étudiants qui organise tous
c'est-à-dire que moi en tant qu'avocat
de la défense merci pour les images
effectivement j'étais plutôt à l'époque
en fait ce que les étudiants faisaient
c'est qu'ils essayaient vraiment de
recréer l'ambiance de de bien insister
sur la procédure en cours d'assise et je
dis pour ça chapeau aux étudiants parce
que tout était absolument parfait dans
la reconstitution je dirais même je m'en
suis rendu compte de manière
involontaire parce qu'il y a quelques
semaines j'étais tiré au sort pour être
jury d'assises
et pour avoir en plus participé à la
reconstitution de procès là je me suis
retrouvé sur le banc des jurés et j'ai
vu donc un procès pour meurtre là aussi
à quel point c'était fidèle ce qui avait
à ce que les étudiants avaient fait lors
de cette reconstitution du Conseil
Landru donc vraiment c'était un conseil
qui avait duré toute une journée et donc
vraiment chapeau aux étudiants et
l'association qui avait organisé ça ils
le font chaque année je pense qu'il le
font encore et c'est une performance
assez assez unique et
en tant que successeur de maître
mouradjafiri puisque vous étiez le
défenseur de de Landry
vous êtes vous plutôt persuadé de sa de
son innocence ou vous jouiez le rôle
pour croire à son innocence alors je
jouais le rôle pour croire à son
innocence mais clairement je pense qu'il
y a aucun doute sur le fait que Landru
était responsable à cette affaire
en réalité et ça montre aussi de
l'avocat de la défense que j'ai vu aussi
en tant que juré d'assise que l'avocat
de la défense il est là pour être la
voie de son client donc si l'andru avait
demandé en son avocat défendez mon
innocence l'avocat doit défendre
l'innocence l'avocat n'est que le
porte-voit le porte-parole de son client
et donc il est aussi tributaire de la
position voulue par son client et là je
défendais forcément une innocence de
Landru alors que bon entre nous j'étais
quand même assez convaincu de sacrifice
d'autant plus d'autant plus que il y a
quelque chose d'intéressant avec Andrew
alors vous allez peut-être déjà un peu
parler avant c'est son côté
nonchalant monsieur tout le monde en
quelque sorte il n'y a évidemment en
permanence donc de être responsable et
puis donc de manière tout à fait
étonnante ce monsieur tout le monde vous
avez il y avait Colette qui assistait au
procès et qui l'a chroniqué le procès
donc l'écrivait de connaître et elle
avait dit dans le journal de matin si je
me suis venu dans l'époque lorsqu'elle
chroniquait ce procès elle avait dit je
cherche encore sous les traits de cette
tête régulière un monstre mais je ne le
trouve pas et c'est vrai que c'était un
peu le problème de l'andrus c'est que il
n'avait pas la tête elle n'est pas le
profil du monstre c'est en commis on se
meurtre si je me souviens bien et puis
de manière assez horrible prémédité
dans dans ce four là à Gambais voilà je
passais les tailles j'imagine que ça a
été suffisamment décortiqué mais c'était
pas évident de défendre un homme qui
était évidemment monsieur tout le monde
absolument écoutez merci de merci
beaucoup d'avoir
d'être intervenu et de nous avoir
rappelé finalement whisky ce qui est une
en effet une initiative excellente de
refaire comme ça des grands procès avec
les étudiants d'abord ça alors apprendre
comment marche la justice et puis et
puis et puis c'est très a toujours très
intéressant et c'est aussi intéressant
en effet de refaire un procès comme on
le ferait aujourd'hui voilà quelques
quelques années bien des années après et
ce d'autant plus si je peux ajouter
Patrice que c'est aussi
œuvre de pédagogie à la fois pour les
étudiants et pour le public qui
assistent pour montrer en fait ce que
c'est qu'un procès ce que c'est que de
rechercher la vérité dans un procès
d'assise pour savoir qui est coupable
qui est-il au sang etc ça montre aussi
qu'elle est l'importance du respect du
principe digne de la présomption
d'innocence et et du contradictoire à
Sciences Po en ligne il y a quelques
années on a refait un autre procès qui
était le procès de Robert brasillac et
ça montre en fait refaire son procès
l'importance du Conseil équitable parce
que il n'avait pas eu droit à un procès
totalement équitable et même si cet
homme était une ordure et coupable de ce
qu'il a fait parce que c'était public
et bien il n'empêche qu'aujourd'hui vous
avez encore des gros muscu d'extrême
droite qui considèrent que la justice
n'a pas été rendu propre brasiliaque et
l'on sait au rang de martyr de la
collaboration etc donc c'est très
important qu'un procès qu'on voit qu'un
procès public il est contradictoire et
qu'on prouve la culpabilité
que tout le monde quel qu'il soit à
droite un procès à un procès équitable
mais merci infiniment Vincent merci et à
très bientôt merci beaucoup alors voici
intéressant de rappeler ce fait alors
parlons de la pièce donc c'est vrai que
les toutes les minutes du procès sont
aux archives je crois des Yvelines oui
et vous êtes donc vous allez vous avez
passé des heures et des heures alors il
y a beaucoup de documents sur internet
et il y a aussi je me suis aussi
beaucoup aidé d'un livre dont le nom
m'échappe mais qui raconte le procès en
fait de façon chronologique du début
jusqu'à la fin d'accord ce qui était
pour moi le point important de cette
création ça a été avec la cohrist de de
réellement en fait chercher le plus de
phrases historiques possible dans cette
démarche de voir dans la vérité de ce
qui s'est passé de de vraiment faire un
procès c'est ce que j'expliquais en
premier abord à la mairie de Gambais
quand j'ai vu le premier échange avec
Monsieur face et avec vous ou
en fait moi je voulais pas faire une
pièce en disant voilà l'endroit est
coupable venez voir son procès je
voulais vraiment refaire le procès au
sens naturel tel qu'il a eu lieu
agrément les éléments qu'ils avaient à
l'époque pour juger avec le plus
avec tout ça j'ajoute que dans les
représentations qui vont avoir lieu donc
le 27 et 28 mai il y aura parmi les
spectateurs des gens qui
et qui seront les jurés donc il va être
jugé il y a le procès qui est la pièce
et il y a un jugement qui peut être qui
peut être en sa faveur ou en sa défaveur
on verra bien et ben c'est ça exactement
on tire au sort 14 spectateurs parce que
sur le procès Landry on sait pas c'est
une demande du du du président Gilbert
en fait qui au vu de l'exercice tout à
fait à l'époque du procès qui en fait
devant l'énormité du dossier a voulu
désigner deux jurys supplémentaires au
début en fait à l'ouverture du procès et
donc du coup il se retrouve avec 14 au
lieu de 12 et donc on tire au sort 14
spectateurs qui iront prendre place à un
endroit juste devant la scène
pour vraiment être dans le dans le
spectacle et qui après iront délibéré
avec le président le comédien qui joue
le Président
on s'est dit que certaines personnes
pouvaient être gênées du regard des
autres et en fait du coup du coup on a
décidé de les mettre dans une pièce
ailleurs pour qu'il soit vraiment en
huis clos comme ça se passerait en vrai
et qu'à la fin il est la vraie surprise
de du verdict on n'a pas on n'a pas les
coulisses de
narrations entre eux et ne sont pas
inscrits dans la pièce et pour la petite
anecdote quand on a joué à ce lieu le 25
mars oui parce que vous avez déjà joué
une fois une première grâce à la ville
de soluwe qui nous a qui nous a permis
cette création
et Landru a été acquitté pour les
meurtres condamné pour escroqueries
Robert Hossein avait fait ses refait de
grands procès d'histoire et par exemple
Marie-Antoinette à chaque fois était
était
acquitté enfin
les résultats qu'on obtenait après les
pièces de théâtre était souvent très
différent de ce qu'ils avaient été on
n'est plus voilà on est plus dans les
mêmes contextes de banque tout à fait et
je pense que symbolique voilà ça parce
que je pense que symboliquement même si
les spectateurs se disent c'est du
théâtre évidemment qu'on ne décapitera
pas Gauthier à la fin de la pièce non
représentations
symboliquement le spectateur à ce
moment-là pourra de façon très
symbolique se dire ok est-ce que
j'envoie cet homme à la mort ou est-ce
que j'ai suffisamment de preuves et de
conviction
pour l'envoyer cet homme à la mort ou
est-ce que finalement
en ayant aujourd'hui les pièces du
dossier et comment s'est passé le procès
est-ce que cet homme réellement il y a
assez de preuve pour ou est-ce que ou
est-ce que est-ce que non on va pas
prendre le risque
en gros mais enfin je ne vois vous faire
dévoiler toute la pièce mais mais en
gros les éléments qui pèsent pour la
culpabilité de dangereux et les éléments
qui
permettrait d'avoir un doute
c'est compliqué
en fait de façon purement
moi Landru personnellement avant
d'écrire sur lui avant de me renseigner
en tout ça je me suis dit il est
coupable il est coupable il a tué toutes
ces femmes etc pour des raisons un peu
banales de se dire que après son
exécution il y a plus de disparition il
y a plus tous ces problèmes là et après
on m'interrogeant vraiment sur la pièce
en ayant beaucoup de discussions avec la
mairie de Gambais en ayant vraiment
beaucoup beaucoup discuté regarder sur
internet des archives documentaires
inains etc il y a quelque chose qui est
assez flagrant c'est qu'en fait l'andru
a été envoyé à la mort sur de simples
convictions et c'est ce que dit maître
Moreau de jafférer à l'époque il dit la
la conviction n'a jamais été une preuve
et c'est dans cette plaidoirie qui
disait parce que tout le procès repose
sur la conviction du commissaire Belin
enfin des Brigades du Tigre de façon
générale parce que c'est eux qui ont
c'est célébrités
et en fait tout repose sur un faisceau
d'indices entre guillemets mais qui en
réalité un vrai pro c'est ça qui est un
faisceau de conviction les experts le
docteur Paul à l'époque est capable de
dire que c'est des restes doucement
humain qu'on retrouve dans cette fameuse
cuisinière mais il est pas capable de
dire que c'est des femmes il est pas
capable de donner un âge il est pas
capable de et on ne peut pas prouver que
c'est Landru qui est réellement en fait
mis c'est c'est c'est
OS c'est restent d'autres dans cette
cuisinière en sachant que au moment de
son arrestation la première perquisition
ils sont venus ils ont tout retourné ils
n'ont rien trouvé ils sont ils ont
quitté la villatrices à Gambais ils sont
revenus une semaine plus tard il n'avait
pas posé de CV et une semaine plus tard
ils ont trouvé plein d'indices
à l'instant c'est que tout le monde a
droit à un procès absolument aujourd'hui
on a du recul en machin sur Landru et
puis que on ne chacun ses convictions
bon moi c'est moi qui le jauge je pense
personnellement que qu'il était coupable
mais mais il y a quand même cette indice
fort c'est que les femmes qui arrivent à
gamber
énormément
on les retrouve pas c'est ça est-ce que
c'est lui voilà comment imaginer que ça
soit quelqu'un d'autre
c'est ici mais en effet vous avez raison
il y a pas la preuve
absolue que que que l'andru à tel point
d'ailleurs que dans le vrai procédé en
1921 donc c'est un moment qu'on ne
pouvait pas se permettre parce qu'on
n'avait pas le temps et c'était une mise
en place qu'il était très compliqué mais
les jurés sont revenus une première fois
en disant l'andru Landru est coupable
donc une peine de mort et le le l'avocat
de la défense en fait maître Moreau
dufferi avait hurlé que c'était une
honte qui n'avait aucune preuve en fait
les les jurés choses assez
exceptionnelles
ce sont ré isolés et sont revenus avec
un recours en grasse qu'ils ont adressé
au président mille errant et qui a été
refusé en fait
d'entrée de jeu parle par le Président
de la République de l'époque alors il y
aurait bien une petite professeur
puisque j'étais j'étais dans le c'était
avec Robert Badinter c'était vieux
c'était en 1984 je suis un matin voilà
il nous convoque je crois qu'on était
deux journées du monde et moi
interne nous dit voilà je vous ai appelé
parce que j'ai la preuve que que l'on
dru est coupable et
il y a c'est un mot qui alors évidemment
l'avocat qu'on connaît ces mots de
jefferi mais comme toujours dans dans
ces procès des grands avocats ils voient
leurs clients deux ou trois fois et
c'est tout et celui avec lequel ils ont
le plus de de rapport c'est c'est le
collaborateur
et
et et
juste avant d'être exécuté
d'andru a donné ce mot aux
collaborateurs de moradjaferi alors il
dit mon cher Maître permettez-moi de
vous offrir ma modeste mon modeste
souvenir fait pendant la préparation des
débats et dans le sujet m'a été inspiré
par les dispositions de témoin
contestables de la Justice de la bêtise
humaine parce qu'on cherche les eaux
derrière le mur à l'époque il dit et
l'on nous dit ce n'est pas le mur
derrière lequel il se passe quelque
chose mais bien la cuisinière dans
laquelle on a brûlé quelque chose et de
me brûler et soulier trois fois
alors
c'est écrit au crayon parce que si
jamais il avait il avait il avait été
gracié par exemple et il aurait pu
effacer ce mot et donc et à partir de là
justice a fait une commission de sur les
archives judiciaires pour pouvoir garder
des archives qui n'étaient pas le cas
donc il y a juste ce petit ce petit
élément qui peut être une preuve après
on pourrait interpréter autrement aussi
non pas bon et puis ce qui est
intéressant c'est pas tant les preuves
contre l'endroit mais c'est le c'est à
quel point est-ce que l'enquête et
l'instruction a été fait comme
l'expliquait un peu par dessus la jambe
quoi pas de passer les poser même
pendant le procès on le montre un peu
pendant la pièce il y a beaucoup de
choses qui sont très limites qu'on
pourrait pas du tout voir dans un procès
équitable justement
des des explosions de colère de la part
de certaines personnes sont assez resté
neutres enfin ben c'est à dire que le
président Gilbert à l'époque était pas
du tout neutre en fait et d'entrée de
jeu en fait avait pris le parti de
maître Godefroy l'avocat général et en
fait maître Godefroy était là pour la
tête de Landry rien d'autre et ce que je
trouve assez intéressant dans cette
direction là c'est que
au moment où l'andouille est condamné à
mort et qu'on sait qu'il y aura pas de
retour en arrière possible il a adressé
un courrier en fait au président et à
l'avocat général une lettre que j'ai
trouvé très dure
ou en fait l'andru
dénonce le comportement qui ont eu en
fait c'est ces deux antagonistes du
procès où en fait il dit mais vous
n'avez pas été capable de me regarder
dans les yeux au moment où vous avez lu
mon verdict vous m'envoyez à la mort et
il termine sa lettre en disant messieurs
je vais mourir l'âme légère et
tranquille j'espère que votre mort sera
de même et je trouve ça jusqu'au bout
il n'a jamais laissé le moindre indice
de cette culpabilité il a toujours nié
quoi jusqu'à mon rôle à la fin c'est mon
petit bagage
c'est mon petit bagage alors
ce procès puisque c'est le cœur de la
pièce il était extrêmement médiatisé
Vincent couronne rappelait qu'avec le
déscrivains comme Colette qui fait le
procès et puis et c'est ce qui fait
aussi le le sel de de votre pièce
c'est que c'est que il a un humour
incroyable Landru ah si en dehors
d'humour c'est un ballon
moi je pense que l'andrus ce serait très
bien défendu en fait je pense que
l'Android était capable de se défendre
sans mettre Moro déjà ferry
tellement il avait du culot et de dire
au président de la cour d'assises
enfin sous-entendre au président de la
cour d'assise qu'il élève mal ses
enfants
entre autres c'est une phrase moi que
enfin c'est un passage que j'avais
énormément de la pièce mais il y a eu
des phrases on se dit mais c'est pas
possible de de dire ce genre de choses
de regarder encore une fois je reviens
dessus mais de regarder le président des
conseils
comment ils obéissent et ça il pose pas
de question et et et et en fait ce qui
est assez incroyable quand j'ai commencé
à vouloir écrire sur l'andru au début je
me suis bah je vais faire une pièce sur
la vie de Landru et très vite je me suis
dit mais au bout d'un moment après trois
disparitions le public va se dire oui
d'accord une disparition c'est une
cinquième ici et en fait on me
renseignant sur le procès le côté
spectacle le côté le Tout-Paris qui
vient à Versailles pour assister au
procès les trains qu'on appelle les
trains Landru qui était affrêter de
Montparnasse à Versailles chantier pour
ramener les politiciens les acteurs les
sénateurs enfin vraiment tout un grand
monde en fait au procès avec des éclats
de rire avec le monde des libérations où
en fait les gens commençaient en venir
aux mains dans la salle et mettre Moro
jefferi ou je crois que sinon c'était
maître Godfroid pardon qui en fait c'est
meilleur mais attendez mais c'est
scandaleux la vie d'un homme qui a
arrêté ça immédiatement vous devriez
avoir honte de vous ce qui est très
paradoxal alors ce qui est très
totalement biaisé avec l'aide du
président et quand les gens viennent aux
mains ils disent mais c'est scandaleux
vous avez la vie d'un homme entre les
mains
c'est un peu comme dans l'affaire
Android il y avait vraiment les les je
dirais les Landes
excusez-moi le Land Rusard et lentilles
c'est vraiment ceux qui pensaient que
l'andru était innocent et il y en a eu
quand même déjà à l'époque et ceux qui
étaient convaincus en partie à cause des
journaux les journaux ont eu un rôle
très important dans dans ce procès ou en
fait les ouais les plus procès avancés
sur les trois semaines et puis les gens
y aller rigolaient il y avait de plus en
plus de monde
quoi c'était déjà une venait déjà au
théâtre voir
absolument mais je pense que avec la
défense que qui avait Landru euh je me
disais il avait rien à perdre il avait
rien à perdre et c'est pour ça qu'il qui
joue énormément avec avec le juge avec
voilà c'est c'est ça il est nerveux tout
le monde parce que je pense que voilà il
se dit coupable j'y suis coupable j'y
reste et puis tant qu'à faire
au mieux c'était le ban et au pire
c'était c'était la mort et à l'époque je
connais pas l'espérance de vie mais il
avait déjà 50 ans et c'est ce que dit
maître Moreau de Ferré dans sa
plaidoirie il conclut en disant
si vous répondez NON au meurtres ça va
être le bagne mais 20 ans de Man ce qui
équivaut à la peine de mort quoi qu'il
arrive pour un homme de 50 ans
voilà c'est le bac très très longtemps
c'est compliqué je pense il y a une
scène qu'on raconte très très souvent
quand on va avec tout le monde presque
codé même même ceux qui sont pas
intéressés au procès Landru c'est cette
scène où je l'ai fait donc l'avocat de
de Landru dit au juré regardez vous vous
êtes persuadé que l'on a tué ces femmes
mais regardez cette porte elle va
s'ouvrir une des femmes dont vous pensez
qu'elle a disparu va apparaître et tous
les jurés se tournent vers la porte et
puis le procureur prend la parole dit
maître c'est vrai que tout le monde
s'est tourné sauf Londres alors ça c'est
une scène absolument extraordinaire elle
est dans la pièce elle est dans la pièce
mais elle n'est pas dans la réalité mais
il n'est pas dans la résiste pas c'est
une légende c'est une fiction c'est une
fiction en fait de la légende urbaine
quasiment c'est parce que tout le monde
va exactement elle est très connue quoi
et on se dit quel talent pour déjà fait
et qu'elle talent du procureur
j'ai été très surpris parce
qu'effectivement au début je ne voulais
pas mettre non c'est une légende et même
trouver un article je me souviens plus
exactement là de quel genre de j'ai lu
mais ça a été pourri c'était ça n'a
jamais eu lieu et en fait en commençant
l'écriture de la pièce avec ma
co-autrice Helena on
a discuté et elle tout de suite de
l'andru c'est ce qui lui revenait et
quand j'en ai parlé à ma famille c'est
ah oui j'espère que le moment de la
porte et en fait je me suis rendu compte
que les gens et même les comédiens quand
j'ai commencé à en parler un peu à
Gauthier à Margot qui joue maître Moreau
ferry
les gens m'ont dit mais cette scène
Veillette j'ai dit ben en fait c'est mon
lit parce que elle n'est pas historique
elle n'existe pas dans la réalité et en
fait face aux réactions des gens de me
parler de cette bon ok on la remet
et aussi extrêmement théâtre ah oui
mais cette scène notamment va aller oui
la réplique de la tête aussi qui qui est
très célèbre ma tête vous ne cessez de
parler de ma tête je regrette de en
avoir qu'une seule à vous offrir c'est
un exemple du culot de Londres encore
une fois
généralement de l'humour de
l'espièglerie même carrément
alors il y a aussi cette le dernier bout
de l'autruche c'est passé quand il est
il va être guillotiné et évidemment il y
a un prêtre qui arrive comme d'habitude
oui il dit est-ce que vous croyez en
Dieu est-ce que Dieu est-ce que selon
vous Dieu existe et l'autre il dit
écoutez je souhaite guillotiner quelques
instants vous voyez que c'est le moment
de me poser des devinettes et juste
avant et juste avant avec la dernière
cigarette ou le dernier verre de Rome il
dit non désolé c'est pas bon pour la
santé
alors celle-là alors on n'a pas pu
garder parce qu'en fait on avait cette
problématique de la salle de théâtre de
pas pouvoir amener la guillotine sur
scène vous êtes dans le procès voilà
exactement je n'ai rien à vous dire de
le retour de la retourne
en fait on a écrit trois femmes
alternatives parce qu'il fallait que en
fonction de ce que ce que le spectateur
le le enfin le juriste spectateur allait
répondre on a trois fins alternatives
que je garde secrète parce que sinon ça
va évoluer voilà dans la 3 fins
alternatives
ah oui selon les selon le jugement
il m'a tenu à coeur de garder quand même
le petit bagage dans une des fins même
si on a un peu tronqué la réalité dans
le sens où il l'a dit pas au tribunal il
l'a dit à la fin mais j'ai dit cette
phrase est tellement mythique beaucoup
de gens la connaissent il faut qu'on la
garde
mais par contre ce passage là je
regrette de vraiment de ne pas l'avoir
mis mais je ne pouvais ça collait pas
dans la pièce c'était pas possible mais
j'aurais beaucoup aimé au moins la
cigarette et le verre de Rome est-ce que
avant de décrire ou pendant que vous
écriviez la pièce vous avez revu je sais
pas les films le film sherbrol oui le il
y a une pièce de rang qui est aussi la
cuisine
voilà
parce que il y a plusieurs
cuisinières parce que c'est un modèle
c'est un modèle de cuisinière de
ménagère donc cette cuisinière donc
avait été achetée sur le territoire de
gambettes de commerce proche de Gambais
et il y a eu plusieurs répliques donc
forcément on se dit j'ai acheté la
cuisinière de Landru et je crois bien
d'accord
[Musique]
c'est une petite
donc vous imaginez cette petite
cuisinière pour brûler un corps encore
[Musique]
c'est vrai que bon ils auraient retrouvé
dans la villa à Gambais plusieurs donc
plusieurs couteaux plusieurs six
semaines mais ce sont des six à métaux
se pas des grosses bouchées ce sont
voilà du petit du grillage de monsieur
madame tout le monde comme était comme
était le personnage de Landru parce que
en tant que mère moi je suis imprégné de
cette histoire depuis que j'habite
j'habite la commune je suis pas venu
habiter à Gambais pour l'histoire mais
quand vous venez à notre rue vous y
intéressez à l'histoire et on vous parle
énormément de Landru et les gambaisiens
les familles historiques de Gambais vous
parlent de cette histoire et vous
replongez dans cette histoire en tant
que en tant que élu pour vous intéresser
bien sûr à cette culture ça fait partie
de la culture de Gambais et beaucoup de
personnes m'ont dit mais vous savez
Monsieur le Maire Landru c'était
monsieur tout le monde quand il venait à
Gambais c'est-à-dire il était poli il
ressemble à quiconque dans la région
[Musique]
qui dit c'est un type fabuleux d'une
intelligence redoutable mais ce n'était
pas un tueur psychopathe c'était un
tueur calculé parce qu'il cuir ses
victimes pour ne pas se faire prendre
au départ ce n'était rien qu'en escroc
au mariage qui est fini par se faire
prendre mais et puis il dit c'est un oui
c'était Monsieur tout le monsieur tout
le monde absolument raison on est sur la
banalité du mal on le fait qu'il
ressemble
ils sont venus vous voir pour vous
proposer alors vous savez à chaque fois
il y a un livre qui sort sur Landru qui
est un article de presse qui sort sur
Landru on ce qu'on appelle l'Amérique
d'Ambert donc on appelle le maire de
Gambais est-ce que vous souhaitez
participer à une interview alors en tant
que en tant que mère on veut tourner la
page de cette histoire
[Musique]
il y a à la fois bon c'est une part de
l'histoire de enfin on peut partager mes
conseils
et tous mes prédécesseurs souhaitent
tourner la page de cette histoire de
Landru et particulièrement quand la
maison a été en vente en 2019 il n'était
pas question que la commune de Gambais
rachète cette cette villa pour faire un
musée voilà non c'est c'est vraiment pas
du tout
l'histoire est passée au contraire on
tourne la page et Monsieur le Maire de
Gambais il veut plus enfin et qu'on
l'appelle monsieur Landru à chaque fois
on s'allume c'est le maire de Landru et
donc
c'est pour ça que Louis quand il appelle
la mairie de Gambais j'ai pas donné la
réponse tout de suite d'accord là de
dire est-ce que oui
ouais régulièrement et comme on dit on
essaie de gommer cette
histoire
ce qui nous a plu dans dans cette pièce
que lui nous a proposé c'est le fait de
rejouer ce procès et de faire participer
les spectateurs en tant que juré et ça
ça peut être intéressant
probablement certains ne connaissent pas
l'histoire de gambettes qui vont
assister d'autres la connaîtront
probablement la connaissance par coeur
voilà et ben en regardant cette cette
pièce plus avec on est en 2023 donc
aujourd'hui on aura peut-être une vision
différente de la culpabilité ou non de
l'Android
c'est l'intérêt qu'on a souhaité voilà
c'est pour cet intérêt qu'on a souhaité
mettre cette pièce à l'affiche de notes
petite salle de Gambais un Gambais et de
1500 habitants on n'a pas un théâtre un
grand théâtre mais on permet quand même
plus de 200 personnes ce samedi 27
d'être présent pour cette représentation
et comme on voit qu'il y a vraiment un
succès de de ce voilà de cette histoire
de ce procès les glaces sont partis de
une vitesse et avec notre petite
communication
locale donc on s'est dit allez Louis les
équipes sont disponibles le lendemain
allez on ouvre une séance le dimanche
et qui est à moitié complète et qui part
voilà et rien qu'avec notre petit réseau
de communication sans aller chercher des
médias un peu plus plus ouverts
et c'est très bien parce que je pense
que le but c'est aussi de faire
connaître cette cette pièce qui est
intéressante que Louis baron
et ses équipes ont mis ont mis en place
et puis je pense que demain cette pièce
pourra aller s'exporter je pense que
c'est ce que souhaite un peu l'équipe
aussi de voir un petit peu ce concept ce
concept d'interactivité aussi c'est ça
qui est intéressant c'est pour ça que
nous on a dit banco et on porte cette
pièce avec lui et puis lui et ses
équipes sont très sympathiques donc
c'était le moment où partager
un peu vierge
au spectacle je veux dire ça
voilà il y a les yeux sans vous dire il
est forcément coupable c'est ce que je
vous racontais [__] tout à l'heure
monsieur Karmous du asso lieu d'une dame
qui est venue me voir qui me dit voilà
alors moi je connais très bien le
dossier d'andru mes parents ont vécu
qu'en Bay vraiment je j'étais convaincu
que coupable
et en vous entendant notamment sur la
liste de procédures je me dis je suis
pas si convaincu que ça en quittant
votre pièce et ça a été le meilleur
retour que j'ai vu je me dis mais on
fait réfléchir les gens et cette pièce
en dehors du côté attractif j'ai surtout
cherché une moyenne en fait depuis le
covid c'est un peu compliqué les
fréquentations de salle le cinéma de
c'est un peu la crise avec la plateforme
de streaming aussi qui qui pullule
chercher un moyen original de donner
envie à quelqu'un un spectateur lambda
de revenir au théâtre de dire ok oui et
il y a un truc qui est assez flagrant
c'est que les tueurs en série ça fascine
et que les cours d'assises elle fascine
il y a un côté un peu voyeuriste dire
oui allô
nous on en a un très bon avec Landru
mais c'est vrai que d'autres orateurs
voilà plus après les avocats et tout ça
ce sont de merveilleuses et on assiste
quelque chose d'exceptionnel
en série français cour d'assis qui déjà
de base est traité théâtrale elle est
validée et c'est pour ça que ça s'est
tourné en procès de Landru parce que
c'était un peu finalement une mise en
abyme comme le procès historique avait
déjà été très théâtral et que la Cour
d'Assise comme le dire Monsieur le Maire
et de base aussi très théâtrale j'ai dit
bah arrive avec une pièce de théâtre qui
met en scène un procès théâtral ça peut
être intéressant sur un tueur en série
et que tout citoyen inscrit sur les
listes électorales peut-être
parce que la notoriété est l'attirance
enfin parce que c'est ça qui c'est vrai
que les criminels attirent souvent je
crois qu'il a eu 800 demandes en mariage
oui
qui lui sont arrivés pendant qu'il était
en prison
il avait un physique
[Musique]
le faux crâne la barbe qui est en
braille quoi ça ça joue vraiment et puis
après c'est beaucoup de travail
il y a du travail documentaire il y a
beaucoup de travail avec le avec le
metteur en scène euh beaucoup de
répétitions l'idée c'est déjà on s'est
beaucoup demandé voilà pour moi est-ce
qu'il est coupable ou pas dans ce cas là
faut jouer un double jeu donc faut jouer
voilà alors il est coupable je le sais
moi Gautier jean-marne mais je joue la
personne coupable qui claque son
innocence et qui en est certain c'est ce
qu'il a fait en tout cas voilà il y a
quelque chose de triple pensée euh moi
je pense qu'il est coupable mais lui
c'est qu'il est coupable mais va se
défendre quand même et puis après c'est
alors il y avait beaucoup de documents
donc on parlait de ces heures distants
claires tout à l'heure qui est le livre
d'Eric young avec beaucoup de pièces
pourquoi 6h10 temps clair
il fait beau quand c'est ça et puis
après alors il y avait également les
films les les notamment le il y a eu un
téléfilm avec
Patrick
[Musique]
ce qui est compliqué dans dans ce
travail c'est qu'en fait on arrive où on
a alors il y a eu beaucoup de choses de
réaliser sur Landru en film téléfilm
nous d'histoires et voilà
bien sûr à chaque fois de vidéo Youtube
à chaque fois un parti pris c'est-à-dire
que Claude Chabrol ne montre pas les
crimes le sous-entend sans vraiment le
montrer c'est à l'interprétation du
spectateur
la version de de Pierre Boutron donc de
télé ciné qui est Patrick Timsit et un
peu mon un peu plus démonstratif
c'est-à-dire que on suggère vraiment que
l'andru les découpe dans la cuisine et
moi je me suis dit non je veux vraiment
quelque chose de neutre je veux pas
vraiment voilà
pièce c'est que voilà on voit assister
au procès il faut comme je disais il
faudrait arriver vierge à se poser et
puis voilà chacun se fera sa conviction
de ce qui était compliqué
c'est ce qui était conclu compliqué pour
Gauthier au début c'est de jongler entre
ce ouais mais bon et ils sont sort
matériaux parce que il y a eu vraiment
beaucoup beaucoup de recherches et un
vrai pot de cauchemar beaucoup de
séparer de séparer le personnage et moi
il y a eu beaucoup de travail on a
beaucoup travaillé notamment sur son
bagou et son culot qui est le très
caractéristique de rue on en reparlé
beaucoup là aujourd'hui
la meilleure réplique selon vous de
l'ordre
il y en a pas mal mais c'est celle que
je vous ai dit tout à l'heure de ma tête
vous parlez toujours de ma tête je
regrette de voir qu'une seule à vous
offrir qui est très qui l'adresse un peu
à la fois à Godefroy donc l'avocat
général et au public
où il y a voilà ce côté je fais un show
il y avait il y avait des photos de lui
quelques photos on le voit avec les
mains en l'air comme ça le doigt levé
voilà cette espèce de posture très fière
enfin et on a beaucoup beaucoup
travaillé ça
et puis la réplique historique je pense
que tous les mais fallait quand même
arriver
fallait que j'arrive à les faire mienne
quand même donc ça apprécié la mise en
scène de trouver le bon truc en étant
proche de la réalité mais sans tomber
dans une copie de ce que vous êtes ici
de ce que vous êtes des nerfs par
exemple donc j'ai regardé les films mais
pour un côté voilà et se saisir d'une
aura et après
mienne avec l'aide de de louer à la
maison
regarde trop ce que ce qui a été fait
avant donc ils ont pas envie de se faire
voilà je les ai regardé une fois une
fois chaque film pas plus évidemment
Raphaël
Gambais c'est comme vous le disiez c'est
pas que Landru non bah non vous savez
qu'est-ce qui se passe
il se passe plein de belles choses
Gambais donc on est dans Fort rappeler
c'est vrai que nos téléspectateurs ne
situent peut-être pas ou si on a parlé
beaucoup de Gambais mais Gambais se
trouve quand même on est proche de
l'Eure-et-Loir faut pas oublier on est à
peine kilomètres de l'Eure-et-Loir donc
Gambais au cœur du parc enfin on fait
partie du Parc naturel régional de la
Haute Vallée de Chevreuse faut savoir
que Gambais fait partie de ce parc
naturel bah oui pourquoi parce que
Gambais c'est la forêt de Rambouillet on
est en pleine forêt de Rambouillet
gambettes très forestier un Gambais
c'est 90 % d'espace naturel et
forestiers on a 10 % d'urbanisés sur
notre territoire et une grande commune
très très vaste étendue on est sur 23 23
km2 donc
2500 habitants 2500 habitants voyez donc
on est à l'aise comme on dit on est bien
donc c'est pour ça que bon ça attire
beaucoup de ça attiré des villas de
prestige des belles maisons à Bombay
donc voilà c'est on s'y plaît bien
Gambais donc on n'a pas le train voilà
il y a pas la gare à Gambais donc ça
c'est une fête non c'est pas une demande
parce que on a celle de Houdan on a
celle de de Méré Monfort donc voilà donc
on a plus les calèches on a plus les
calèches parce que
avec la calèche maintenant on a les
véhicules on a on a les vélos donc voilà
vous savez que c'est une ville très très
agréable et comme vous dites c'est un
paradis c'est ça c'est ça opporte au
port de Paris et on est le poumon un des
poumons verts de des Yvelines aussi on
est ravi de quand on émerve de Gambais
on est ravis d'administrer cette cette
ville de Gambais et de se détacher mais
on a parlé beaucoup pendant 7 heures de
de Landru mais ce n'est pas que voilà
c'est un beau château c'est le Château
De Neuville c'est beaucoup de petits
commerces des maisons avec de beaux
cachés
il est fait bon vivre absolument et puis
il y a un théâtre quand même voilà dans
ce théâtre donc théâtre on y propose
donc le samedi 27 dimanche 28 samedi 27
19h dimanche 28 à 16h 16h je n'ai rien à
vous dire c'est la phrase et qui voilà
et qui est une des phrases les plus
célèbres de ce procès qui est donc
rejoué et puis si vous allez vous pouvez
juger l'andru voilà c'est quand même
formidable on a plus beaucoup l'occasion
maintenant de voter la mort de quelqu'un
sauf en étant tiré voilà bon
Raphaël nivoit merci infiniment
et à très bientôt alors et puis et puis
merde
[Musique]